we are here with and just like that star
kristen davis and ross
the ultimate sex in the city trivia
showdown
adorable all right over in this corner
she appeared in all 94 episodes of sex
in the city plus both movies that the
always lovable believes in true love
charlotte it's kristin davis
[Applause]
and in this corner she watched all 94
episodes of stefan city plus both movies
when they came out and she recently
binged them all again from the comfort
of her couch wearing sweatpants it's
drew barrymore
i've seen every episode 10 times of
course
i'm i'm interested to see what i've done
with all of this information
i hope you retain some because these
questions are tough i'm going to ask you
a series of questions they're all based
on sex in the city you're going to buzz
in with your answers drew you're playing
for this half of the audience all right
hi guys
and kristen you are playing for the
other half of the audience
and whoever gets the most questions
right wins a big surprise for their set
of the audience all right so pay
attention
all
all
right
all right focus you know we take this
very seriously around i am i'm nervous i
can tell you're actually i'm nervous too
okay here's question number one in the
episode ring-a-ding-ding how much money
does miranda estimate carrie spent on
shoes in her lifetime
okay kristen roughly a down payment on
an apartment a hundred thousand dollars
no okay not far off all right um
25 000
okay they did the math
they decided she had spent 40 thousand
dollars on
in between between us i didn't remember
such a specific number no me neither
meaning well i remember because they
were talking about five dollars a pair
for each monologue anyway it's not about
me it's about you guys zero points on
the board
question number 10 you were there all
right but okay question number two sorry
sorry guys when charlotte suggested to
trey that they get married what did trey
say
oh drew you were first alrighty then
[Applause]
i
[Applause]
[Applause]
question number three and they just get
harder take a look at this here are two
cupcakes one is from magnolia's bakery
made famous by sex in the city and one
is not
please identify the magnolia cupcake
b a or b
drew you're locking in on b i'm locking
it on b yeah it is a
oh darn it
kristen we're going to give you a point
all right
thank you very much
thank you very much which means we have
a tie game here's question number four
the next question is a photo scramble
take a look at this who is this actor
who guest starred on the show not once
but twice as two different characters
justin thoreau the answer is justin
throne
you remember the best character ever
yeah
the mommy's boy linda lavin
mom yes yeah he's the only man to guest
star twice as different characters yeah
in season one he was stanford's friend
right and in season two he's the one
that didn't last that long if you know
what i mean yes yeah
well guess what what the winner of the
ultimate sex and the city trivia
showdown is
kristen
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but guess what audience it doesn't
matter who won because we all win
you're all going home with a 300 gift
card to one of drew's favorite beauty
brands drunk elephants
[Applause]
i would like to personally thank the
company drunk elephant those are
incredible high quality products so
honored to be i know i'm like oh really
yeah i i would like that gift i love
them i i would
you're gonna get one
i win too much and you get to keep those
cupcakes yeah exactly fantastic we love
you so much we love you guys too
i just want to say on top of that that
is our pleasure to be back i mean we are
thrilled just to be together it was just
a dream and a half for all of us and so
thank you guys thank all the fans
because that's why we're back
i'm so glad that there is the reception
that is warranted for this incredible
it's more than a show it's
it's a life lived with a lot of memories
and i want to check in and i want to
hear you how you feel and think i will
let you know everything i want to know
and everything in between absolutely all
right and you can
and just watch that every thursday on
hbo max
[Music]